this summer officially marks the release
of a movie which is a melting pot of
former stars all grouped together into
one movie for your nostalgic
entertainment I'm talking of course of
the grown-ups grown-ups sorry for the
bait and switch but let's face it
grown-ups is pretty much the Expendables
of comedy
let's open up for the Expendables sake
okay so grownups is a story of five high
school friends all reconnecting after
the death of their old basketball coach
headed up by Adam Sandler or at least
his stunt double the fivesome in their
families I'll go to a cabin to reconnect
with their youth for a weekend all right
so let's face it it's been a summer of
just mediocre movies nothing stands out
as particularly really good they stepped
Toy Story 3 that was awesome or really
shitty I mean everything's just been
right in the middle but happy medicine
has broken that mold with the first
movie that is truly awful what
makes this movie worse for me is I
remember really liking Billy Madison and
happy gilmore granted I haven't seen him
since junior high but when I was in
junior high I remember liking him
because to be honest every scene in this
movie is just a three-minute setup for
one joke then it moves on to the next
scene which is another three minutes set
up for one joke and then rinse and
repeat for two hours and the jokes
aren't smart I mean I don't know about
you but I just need brains with my
comedy it got so routine like that that
when a punchline would happen in these
scenes I'd go scene change and sure
enough it was a scene change I'm not
psychic I don't think it's just
predictable example there's a scene that
starts where kids are skipping rocks on
a lake you know like kids do and you
think okay so show that kids are having
fun now but salma hayek goes down to the
lake and says hey can I try she skips a
rock smacks her kid in the stomach oh is
slapstick and then the scenes over it
just existed for that but all the scenes
are like the heck's but do I consider
funny okay King of Queens funny
scrubs back when it was funny funny
community really funny the burbs if
everyone just kind of came out of left
field but it's funny grown-ups no it's
not it I mean I had a couple of funny
moments and a couple of hot girls in
particular and a good message about how
kids should go play out in the Sun more
and not bury their heads in their
electronics so much which I agree with
and it's sadly ironic that I pretty much
told kids not to watch this video but to
go outside and play about this watch
this video then go outside and play but
in the end it doesn't make sitting
through daddy day camp comedy for two
hours worth it which is really a bummer
because all the actors in this movie
have talent I mean we've seen them do
better things just not together I guess
so don't go watch this movie don't rent
it don't buy it don't download it for
free just don't watch it I'll give you
the underlying message of this movie
right here for free go outside play have
fun this summer there free of charge how
I roll
maybe they're greasing you up for
desperation so you like Eclipse I don't
know but don't watch this movie but if
you like what you've seen here and you
want to see more than click right here
to see more